[Music]
read it with an open mind
about my mom I'm telling you I come for
you tension was high on Sunday's Keeping
Up with the Kardashians as the famous
family reacted to Caitlyn Jenner's
memoir the secrets of my life if this is
the way that someone feels about me
after 23 years and about all the
wonderful memories that I am then it's
just better for me to say you know what
I have my own memories and they were
great and the last five years were hard
but I still have those great memories
yeah so I choose to be the bigger person
Kris visibly emotional over Caitlyn's
claims about their relationship and
finances she's so angry at mom like for
no reason it was like I didn't speak to
my sister because of Kris I didn't see
my kids because of Kris she said I
didn't see a dime of my money
she was insinuating that like mom took
the check and pocketed a candle Jenner
was equally upset by what the former
Olympian said about her siblings the end
of the day she raised the Kardashians at
the end of the day the Kardashians are
still part of my blood she's really
pushing herself further and further away
from all of us though and then she
complains like why don't you guys come
and hang out with me why don't you guys
see me and it's like because you're
being mean
et spoke with Caitlyn last May at the
GLAAD Awards she explained why she's so
proud she went public with her story we
started a conversation about a small
segment of our population but they are
out there it's been the most amazing
year of people coming up and talking
about this issue
[Music]
you